all right once again good morning good
evening wherever you are
Happy Easter once more to those who are
celebrating I hope you had a good time I
hope that I'm sure a lot of us might
have a really big meal and I hope that
you had a good time despite it just
being at home with your family okay so
today's workout is going to be a
kickboxing and also abs workout because
you might have always indulged over the
weekends and today's session is all
about sweating it out and really working
on your car okay so before we get
started I just want to run through the
three basic principles when it comes to
keep boxing so the first principle is
your feet position okay so imagine that
you're standing
ok everybody knows how to do a squat
correct so imagine standing sugar with
the power with your toes pointed forward
what I wanted to do is bring your right
leg back okay
so left leg is always forward right leg
is always back so that's the starting
position and you should always be in
this position throughout okay so you
should never be squared on it should
always be left leg forward right leg
back
second principle to follow is to always
make sure that you're guarding your face
okay this is where your opponent would
want to punch you kick you hook you so
you have to make sure that both arms are
always up okay so always making sure
that you're protecting your face because
you don't want to be punched or kicked
so always making sure that your your
entire body is tight all right
and the third thing to remember that
kickboxing is a total body workout
therefore you're not just punching using
your arms it's about movement from your
hips your core and your torso area so if
it hold the body workout it's about
transferring the energy and power from
your core to your upper body so every
movement
it's about twisting and using your hip
mobility
and the power here okay it's not this
it's what transferring that all right
got that so three things to remember and
what I wanted to do is apply these
principles in today's session okay all
right so let's do a little bit of warmup
I just want to imagine that you have a
rope and just gently hop on the spot
okay nice and easy we're just warming up
all muscles gently hop on the spot good
so warming up your ankles your calves
and your entire body as well good keep
going
hop nice and remember relax your wrist
and just breathe in and out okay good
keep going and now opening up your hip
flexor side and side okay push it out
and bring it out good out and out again
as you can see I'm already having my
arms right close to my body opening out
out to the left and to the right okay
and now just twist side to side very
good twisting your body side to side and
just shuffle okay left and right shuffle
your legs shuffle good keep shuffling
and now just shake it off okay the first
movement is going to be a jab and cross
okay let's start with the basic so left
leg forward right leg back arms up give
me a jab and across okay remember that
the movement is from your hips your core
and punch straight ahead so you should
have a target in front of you punching
straight ahead punch there you go punch
and pull it back strong punches pull it
back strong left and right and pull me
back good and that's a slight rotation
on the ankle and you're feel okay left
and right left and right all right keep
going and very good it's straight on to
AP's
crab toe touch so get on to the floor up
what a way to do is tap the opposite
side okay so your active rest is going
to be your app workout good
tap it only 30 seconds keep going tap
good reach as high as you can push your
butt up and reach for your toes keep
going up can you see me
is it okay and okay come back up all
right it's back to sorry gotta adjust my
mic slightly is falling up it's back to
Jeff and punch okay everything's too
clear nice so remember left leg forward
right leg back power from your shoulders
from your hips very good use the
momentum and keep creasing okay paste it
up breathe in and out every time you
punch that's when you want to breathe
out
whoo-hoo very good let's go one two one
two back down okay this is your active
recovery up
crap toe touch tap and tap very good
keep going you got this and right after
this it's going to be a new move okay
tap there you go find your rhythm last
few more five more seconds right and
left crossing over lift your glutes up
and back up alright okay
the next movement is going to be a hook
okay so again left leg forward right leg
back arms up left hook right hook
imagine you're punching someone on their
chicks okay so left again look at my
twist your entire body should be facing
the opposite side and right okay left
hook right hook there you go
always making sure that one arm is
always guarding your face all right
so we will be doing that for 40 seconds
I'm stop left leg forward right leg back
and always stay light on your toes ready
let's go
punch hook hook twist look straight
ahead
do not look down your opponent is not on
the floor okay so you want to be making
sure that you're focusing on your
opponent otherwise you're gonna get
punched keep going left that right hook
it tighten your core suck your belly in
okay suck your belly in left and right
hook very good high core tight body
whoo-hoo breathe out nice last four
three two one okay
now let's get down onto the floor active
recovery knee tucks okay so licks
forward tuck it in push it up tuck it in
and out very good
working on your upper and your lower abs
okay going halfway there and we're going
to come back up into hooks straight legs
kick it out few more give me four more
one two three four okay let's come back
up and let's get straight into hooks
left hook right hook good twisting
imagine that the energy is moving from
your hips to your upper body look
straight ahead
hook nice keep going
breathe out
strong energy guys keep it up twist
twist
pivot pivot on your toes pivot good look
straight ahead
look at me okay very good so elbows up
hook do not drop your elbows hook last
one more and active recovery knee tucks
let's get down onto the floor okay let's
go tuck it in and out good
take this time to catch your breath but
we are still working on your abs very
nice keep going if you need to you can
rest your Hughes on to the floor if not
keep it going last four more one two
three four all right
well done 40 seconds rest okay okay now
let's move on and work on our lower body
the next move is going to be a lunch and
a push kick alright so starting on your
left foot take a left step back as you
come up push forward okay
so it's a gentle push to kick you're
putting away alright so remember as you
kick with your left foot
you want to be dropping your left arm so
lunch back as you kick drop it
that's when you're gonna use more
momentum and energy to push the person
further away all right so only on your
left side let's go down push lunge
breathe out good lunch down kick so a
little bit of cardio movement here keep
going
kick good nice kick it push it as high
as you can
let's go drop it and drive your hips
forward okay
drive your hips forward and kick good
kick
last one more and active recovery let's
get down into a plank cross so left to
right elbow and right to left elbow okay
cross cross good making sure that you're
in a strong plank position solid plank
do not pipe your butt up okay cross keep
going
let's go that's two more and back ah
okay so we've worked on our left side
now let's work on our right side okay so
right leg back drop it and kick push
kick good you'll find that one side is
usually stronger than the other side
remember to drop your right hand keep
going push whoa
feel the burn on your left ice as well
push push nice kick in
drop your right arm that's two more
that's one more active recovery let's
get down into flank cross okay left and
right so reaching your right knee to
your left elbow and your left knee to
your right elbow okay halfway there and
you're gonna get a short break after
this keep moving
nice three more one two three and
sweating already
come back up okay the next move is going
to still be working on your lower body
okay it's going to be nice so what I
want to do is starting on your right leg
left leg forward right knee imagine and
that's your grab grabbing hold of
someone and really driving the person's
face our body into your knee okay so the
goal here is to push your hips forward
and straight into the opponent all right
got this so left leg forward right click
back again grabbing hold of someone BAM
okay come on team
we're strong let's go huh who is that
person I don't want to know let's go
nealy push remember it's about driving
your hips forward okay it's not about
driving your knee up it's about driving
your knee forward and your hips forward
so grab that person don't rush through
getting the right technique it's more
important
Sonne good it's up onto your toes and
breathe out keep going now a few more
give me two more okay strong knees drive
the hips forward
that's one more
okay active recovery get down slap the
kicks alright so just support your upper
body licks straight up flutter kicks
okay so small movement that really works
on your lower abs keep going breathe
stay with me
Oh feel the burn last five more seconds
breathe out okay and back up okay now
with your left knee it's going to be a
little bit tricky what I want to do is
switch left knee okay step back switch
left knee left back right back
switch me okay good let's go switch left
knee good step back one two switch two
three four one two three four switch two
three four got that switch two three
four let's go power up whoo keep going
give me three more keep going
mean that's two more one more okay get
back down flutter kicks onto your arms
butter good working on your lower abs
keep going up and down only small
movement okay you don't have to make
this movement very big at all last ten
seconds five seconds
and you are done okay
drink some water if you need to wipe
your flat all right the next two
circuits is going to be a combination
move that means we want to work on our
upper body combining it with our lower
body alright you have 20 more seconds
and I'm gonna explain it to you the
first move is going to be a jab cross
down explosive lunges and back up if
this is too much remove the hop jab
cross lunge take a step back and back
okay so choose your option combining
upper body and lower body let's go jab
cross down explode up down explode up so
remember the three main principles okay
um it's always up twist your hips and
left leg forward right leg back up good
okay keep going
that's one more okay and shake it out
okay now let's get down okay it's going
to be a short plank knee tap so hover
all I want to do is tap your left and
your right knee okay
so your knees should be two to three
inches off the floor
keep going tap tap and tap
do not Pike it but up this is wrong keep
it low and tap and do not move your hips
to the left and to the right too much
last five more seconds
and back ah okay you know what's next
let's go jab punch explosive lunges
energy up down keep going
explode up breathe out when it's
toughest okay there you go
imagine you're Bruce Lee okay that's two
more okay hop hop last one more punch
punch okay get back down into a short
plank knee tap oh what a Monday morning
all right ah tap tap good active
recovery
lots of isometric hold really to
activate your core to fatigue your leg
muscles as well keep going halfway there
ten more seconds tap tap stay low
knees just few inches off the floor and
last one more and back up okay all right
final final workout oh I am feeling you
okay
so we just repeat the music okay so
let's go the final workout is going to
be hook hook left and right drop down
onto the floor into a sprawl knee chest
onto the floor back up left hook right
hook okay so as you get down onto the
floor I want you to challenge yourself
and bring your chest to the floor and
push yourself back up alright guys this
is your final circuit final two minutes
let's go hook hook drop chest onto the
floor up
hook nice remember strong hooks pivot on
your toes and every move they should be
strong okay oh oh nice up let's go you
are badass never miss the Monday
hey we're starting on Monday strong
chance onto the floor back up that's one
mark up hook hook let's get down onto
the floor push yourself back up okay
find a co-worker way to do is step
Heather edge of your mat keeping your
leg straight inch forward into a high
plank tap reach for your ankle and
slowly inch back by still keeping your
hamstrings and your leg straight okay so
inch forward tap and get your core tap
and slowly inch back up let's go one
more high plank tap tap and slowly push
yourself back up okay final run hook
hook sprawl chance onto the floor up
left and right
remember once you get up left leg
forward hook hook okay very good
this is your final 40 seconds down
okay guys you are done that was a twenty
minute total kickboxing workout all
right I hope you had a good time I hope
you are sweaty like me okay now let's
take a breather
let me know in your comments below how
did this workout go if you enjoyed it if
you want more kickboxing and apps if you
want more live sessions let me know in
the comments below okay